in a massive interview with the Verge
valve shared the future of the steam
deck including what we should expect
from the steam deck too here are some
highlights from the conversation the
steam deck has been a wildly successful
product for valve which is incredible to
think of when you realize that Steam
Machines a spiritual predecessor to the
device that the company partnered with
PC manufacturers on and were designed as
computers for your living room crashed
and burned but it now seems that the
success of the steam deck has
revitalized valve's interest in the
steam machine as the team gears up to
make the handheld steam OS available to
third parties steam deck designer
Lawrence Yang explains that not only is
he excited by the handhelds that other
companies could make utilizing the
operating system but the team is looking
forward to manufacturers bringing back
steam machines with it while the steam
deck isn't the only handheld gaming
device on the market it's one of the
cheapest as well as the most powerful
however that's a about to change once
products like the Aya neo2 hit the scene
which utilize an AMD 6800u chip that in
testing has shown to provide more
performance than valve's own custom
aerith SOC steam deck designer Pierre Lu
Griffey isn't too worried about those
devices however as they've proven to be
way less power efficient than the steam
deck tests have shown that the AMD chip
would drain the steam deck's battery
around twice as quickly as its current
processing units does the team seems
happy with the steam deck's performance
which leads them to talk about what
performance on a steam deck 2 would look
like and according to Yang graffey the
performance would look a whole lot like
what you're getting on your current
steam deck it seems valve will be taking
a switch OLED route for its next device
iterations rather than something akin to
the mythical switch Pro by targeting
improvements to both the steam deck
screen and battery life and keeping
performance even with steam deck 1.0
stating that they'd only look to
increase perform
if there were quote significant gains to
be had that's a ton of interesting
details from the steam deck team but it
just scratches the surface of what was
shared so make sure to go check out the
full interview after watching this video
in that information wet your whistle and
speaking of information that wets our
whistles Spider-Man 2 has a more locked
down release window originally announced
as launching in 2023 on PS5 PlayStation
has confirmed that it is targeting a
full release next year for the game
following an accidental posting of a
wishlist page for the game as well as an
insomniac employee putting a full 2023
window on their personal website
PlayStation has confirmed that the end
of next year will indeed be the time
period the game will release barring any
delays please spider gods don't let
there be a delay so far we don't have
many details on what to expect from the
game but both its trailer and the new
announcement post heavily imply it will
feature both Peter Parker and Miles
Morales as playable characters the
trailer features the villain Venom as
well as voiceover from what seems to be
the villain Craven the hunter if both
those bad guys hint to you that this
will be a darker game than the first
you'd be right as Marvel game's Vice
President Bill Roseman equates the
sequel to The Empire Strikes Back
juxtaposed to what he describes as
Spider-Man 2018's A New Hope which
really is saying something if you've
played through the end of Spider-Man
2018 you know what else is dark space
the setting for bethesda's next game
Star field which we got a few tidbits of
info on around the game's factions
unlike previous Bethesda games where
aligning with certain factions would
generally lock you out of teaming up
with others it seems Starfield will
allow you to see and do every Mission
related to every faction in the game
regardless of whether the goals of a
faction oppose another's the faction
quests will also be more personal to the
player but the decisions they make will
still have far-reaching consequences and
their companions will have a quote a lot
of opinions and points of view about
what decisions you'll be making what do
you think about the idea of there being
a steam deck OLED versus a steam deck
Pro let us know in the comments below
we'll see you here for more Gamespot
news
[Music]